the sport can develop  keeping some of the all traditional  things which is good that we keep it but  also  how can we look at it from a fresh eye  to be able to keep the sport interesting  is no longer interested sorry to  interrupt i think this game is over yeah  f4 takes and they shake hands  we have our first draw  was another very interesting fight but  in the end i guess i had to defend and  he managed  very interesting game how many moves 71  71 yeah  right there  we have to say in general the chess  content is great now we have two  decisive games on the first day then the  draw was also incredibly hard fought  with  sacrifices back and forth  well we are not going to have such an  entertaining days every day i believe  i mean looking at this game i mean  you're unbeaten